REMEMBER, THIS IS THEIR SUMMER.
- NO WAY, DUDE.
I'M TRYING TO GET
BEYONCE DARK!
- SUN IS STRAIGHT DANGER!
- DON'T WORRY, DUDE.
I GOT THE SELF TANNER.
IT'S GOOD TOO.
LINDA HOGAN ENDORSES IT.
- HEY, HAS ANYBODY
SEEN MY TEVAS?
I REALLY NEED MY TEVAS.
- HEY, FELLAS,
PLEASE REMEMBER.
I GOT US DINNER RESERVATIONS.
THANKSGIVING DINNER
AT PASTAFARI,
SO PACK A FANCY OUTFIT.
I'VE GOT A BLAZER,
NO SHIRT.
THAT'S WHAT I'M THINKING.
BUD, DERS, YOU'RE KINDA GQ.
SHOULD THE TIE
MATCH MY NIPPLES?
- HA HA!
GUYS, I FOUND MY TEVAS.
- JUST SO YOU KNOW,
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO END
MY 11-MONTH DRY SPELL,
BUT WE'RE DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
SEEING EACH OTHER BUTT NAKED
HUMPING STUFF.
I JUST HOPE
WE'RE READY FOR THAT.
- OH, YEAH. BUDDY'S A GO.
- BLAKESTER IS READY
TO GET HIS KNOB GOBBLED.
- ALL RIGHT!
LET'S GET WEIRD!
- OKAY, EVERYONE HAS
THEIR PLANE TICKET, RIGHT?
- YEAH, I THOUGHT WE WERE
CHANTING "LET'S GET WEIRD."
- GOOD TO GO!
- OKAY, BATHING SUITS?
- CHECK!
- I WILL NOT BE WEARING
A BATHING SUIT.
SO, NO.
- AND, UH, PASSPORTS.
- OH, YEAH!
- HUH?